la masturbation jouit d'une mauvaise
réputation je parle de l'eau nanisme
hein se masturber soi-même parce que
branler des dindons c'est socialement
acceptable mais toucher ses propres
parties génitales ces péchés la
masturbation provoque des problèmes
d'éjaculation précoce non ça peut même
être un très bon moyen d'apprendre à
gérer son équipe d'action et à contrôler
l'éjaculation la masturbation rend
non plus bon chez les femmes on voit
vraiment pas pourquoi mais chez les
hommes non plus en fait les
spermatozoïdes sont fabriqués en
permanence depuis la puberté jusqu'à la
mort quel que soit la fréquence de
l'éjaculations c'est vrai que si vous
voulez faire un bébé vaut mieux espacer
les rapports sexuels de 48 heures pour
laisser le temps au stock de se
renouveler mais il se renouvelle pas
moins bien si vous consommez plus que
d'habitude la masturbation affaiblit le
corps et l'esprit nul 0 ok après un
orgasme qui soit masturbatoire ou pas
d'ailleurs les endorphines libérés par
l'organisme ça provoque un sentiment de
plénitude de Faurie un relâchement
musculaire voire un petit coup de pompe
mais c'est passager et évidemment à long
terme ça entame ni votre force physique
ni votre volonté tu es un très bon moyen
de découvrir son corps